será tan solemne como único será un
cortejo que durará 38 minutos saldrá del
palacio de
buckingham a las 12 y 22 de la tarde
tardará 38 minutos en llegar hasta el
parlamento que ustedes pueden ver a mis
espaldas será impresionante el ataúd de
la reina que ha sido elaborado en roble
llevará la bandera en estandarte del
reino unido- la bandera de la monarquía
tendrá también la corona de estado que
es impresionante raúl tiene más de 2800
diamantes y miles más joyas preciosas la
reina en una entrevista dijo una vez que
si ella se agacha va un poco a leer un
documento con la corona puesta podría
partirse el cuello pesa alrededor de un
kilo luego el féretro será transportado
por un carruaje que será jalado por
siete caballos negros recorrerá
alrededor de dos kilómetros por las
principales calles del centro de londres
participarán cerca de 500 soldados de
varios regimientos reales integrantes de
las fuerzas armadas británicas luego la
familia real además esto es bien
importante para ese recorrido a piedra
del príncipe william y su hermano jardín
también el rey carlos tercero y sus
hermanos y veremos entonces esas
imágenes también sonará el 'big ben'
cada minuto y se escucharán salvas de
cañón en el hyde park para las personas
que no puedan ingresar a ver esta
ceremonia ahí les cuento miles y miles
agolpadas en las afueras del palacio de
putina se ha habilitado una pantalla
gigante en el hi park para que las
personas puedan darle el último adiós a
isabel segundo las que no puedan
ingresar aquí al parlamento a la cámara
ardiente